E aí
[Música]
e quantas vezes você já ouviu em
propagandas vídeos na internet ou até
mesmo em palestras que a estética afro
dos cabelos é mais do que simplesmente
uma estética
certamente algumas dezenas de vezes né
mas o que que de fato isso significa o
quê que tanto dizem por aí que existe
por trás Desses cabelos quando eu era
criança aprende indiretamente que era
importante tornar o meu cabelo invisível
até os meus 67 anos são os domingos às
mulheres a minha casa sentar vamos
comigo para domar o meu cabelo eu
sentava no chão entre as pernas de
alguma delas e esperava que o mesmo
processo de sempre fosse realizado
desfaz a trança da semana anterior lava
seca e faz o penteado todo novamente por
volta dos meus 7 anos eu descobri o
segredo para que os meus cabelos
pudessem estar todos eram muito fácil
bastavam Atom e
se antes eram uns puxões Depois vieram
as químicas fortes que machucavam o meu
cabelo e o meu couro cabeludo era
doloroso mas era uma solução
por tudo isso eu cresci meio ficou uma
repulsa né quanto ao meu cabelo natural
e aquelas trancinhas que podiam ter
algum significado e foi assim durante
muitos anos para muitas de nossas
meninas negras com seus cabelos alisados
e menos negros com seus cabelos raspados
e em um país em que mais de 55 porcento
da população é negra sei que a sua
história não é só minha e que eu
partilho isso como muita gente muitos de
vocês sabem bem o que que sonho são
esses puxões e alisamentos tão
agressivos nossos cabelos crespos
historicamente foram enxergados né como
surgiu sinônimo de desleixo feios e por
conta disso estas eram as únicas saídas
Que nós tínhamos até então acontece aqui
hoje eu não tô aqui para reforçar uma
narrativa de dor a nossa história a
história da população afro-brasileira
Não começa a partir da escravidão bem
como a história dos nossos cabelos e
penteados não começam nos colchões e
alisamentos que eu acabei de contar
Esses são na verdade períodos pequenos
diante de quem somos como já diria a
Jurema Werneck uma das maiores
intelectuais negras brasileiras nossos
passos vêm de longe Ah e por isso a
história Desses cabelos que vim contar
para vocês começa em uma África
pré-colonial bem antes dessa história
convencionalmente contada antes mesmo
das invasões europeias em África
centenas de povos viviam espalhados pelo
continente Cada Um Com Seus costumes e
as suas particularidades ao longo dos
séculos para Esses povos o trato com os
cabelos e as várias formas de trans a
luz e entrelaça Luz eram parte
fundamental dos ritos e dos significados
pertencentes a sociedade em que viviam
em diversas tradições Africanas a cabeça
pulseira a parte mais elevada do corpo
sempre foi isso Sagrada representando um
ponto de conexão com seus guias
espirituais diferentes penteados com
desenhos e formas variadas poderiam
significar coisas distintas como o
status social a passagem para a vida
adulta
a idade ou algum rito ligado a
espiritualidade também poderia indicar o
seu poder econômico a sua função
política o seu estado civil e muito mais
e nesse sentido a forma como se moldavam
os cabelos remetia uma identificação da
posição que aquela pessoa ocupava no
mundo dentro e fora da sua comunidade
por isso inclusive em muitos casos o
fato de uma pessoa não andar com os
cabelos trançados por exemplo era
sinônimo de falta de apreço desvelo e e
simbolizavam a provavelmente que aquela
pessoa estava ou de luto ou tinha
passado por alguma perda o Ofício que
trançar cabelos era um trabalho confiado
a mulheres mais velhas a membros da
família ou alguns amigos íntimos era
preciso uma certa proximidade né entre
essas pessoas e relações Profundas eram
criadas e fortalecidos durante o ato de
transar era um processo que espreitavam
os laços entre idosos e crianças a minha
mulheres de diferentes gerações também e
a partir disso transmitia se e adiante
esse saber estão tradicionais um dos
exemplos de como esses cabelos estão
atreladas a fase da vida e ao Status é o
povo rimba localizado o
predominantemente no que hoje é o norte
da Namíbia nesta comunidade desde o
nascimento os penteados identificavam
visualmente lugar social de cada pessoa
especialmente para mulheres por exemplo
uma jovem pertencente a esse grupo e que
ainda está na infância tem como Penteado
duas tranças na frente da cabeça até
atingir a puberdade já na puberdade as
garotas passam a usar tranças que cobrem
o seu rosto deixando os homens saberem
que ela não está pronta para casar e já
após a puberdade quando mais jovem já
está pronta para casar essas mesmas
mechas serão trançadas para parte de
trás da cabeça permitindo que potenciais
pretendentes vejam seu rosto por fim o
cabelo dessa mulher muda mais uma vez e
depois que ela já está casada há um ano
ou teve seu primeiro filho ela começa a
usar um adereço como é conhecido como o
eremb para identificá-la com uma mulher
casada
o presente nos dias de hoje o povo rimba
é um exemplo de como algumas tradições
africanas ainda se mantêm vivas e fazem
parte dessa história milenar que eu
acabei de contar e com isso não fica
difícil entender quando eu digo que
esses penteados representam
e a essa altura Já conseguimos começar a
entender que não estamos falando de
qualquer história estamos falando de uma
história que inclusive estrategicamente
nunca nos foi contada é quase impossível
encontrar narrativas ou produções
culturais que retomem minimamente o que
foi dito aqui sem atravessar uma noção
quase que dia lenda o misticismo ou até
mesmo o romantizada sobre esses períodos
como Historiador a durante a minha
graduação foi muito difícil encontrar
materiais historiográficos que se
relacionavam a espírito da história e as
esculturas E além disso era muito
difícil encontrar espaço e condições
para desenvolver esses estudos de forma
aprofundada na universidade inclusive
por falta de referências mesmo né Por
parte de professores
e
portanto o debate EA pesquisa sobre as
tradições étnicas africanas é ainda
muito desafiador devido a esse difícil
acesso né uma historiografia referente a
esse conhecimento e existe ainda um
ponto muito importante sobre tudo isso a
manutenção do racismo estrutural
Depende de que a narrativa contada sobre
nós pessoas negras seja a
predominantemente de dor de Sofrimento
dos anos de Servidão ao sistema e nesse
sentido obviamente não caberia a contar
sobre as riquezas e as complexidades na
forma de se organizar e de se expressar
esteticamente através dos cabelos que
para nós é uma herança e mais que isso
um dos pilares da nossa noção de beleza
abundância e prosperidade
obviamente eu não estou aqui ignorando
os impactos da escravidão na forma como
lidamos com os nossos cabelos eu entendo
que ter dimensão dos séculos de
repressão estética é ou não o processo
de transição e o uso das Tranças
simbólico e até mesmo o revolucionário
entretanto o gesto mais Libertador é
perceber que a retomada dessa
consciência é importante não pelos Anos
de Escravidão e sim pelo que nós já
fomos um dia enquanto o povo Sim nós
temos um ponto de partida temos uma
história Próspera e ter conhecimento
disso é muito mais do que uma mera
curiosidade é essencial ter contato com
narrativas positivas sobre o nosso
próprio passado é uma das Ferramentas
mais importantes para que a
ressignificação ou até mesmo construção
da nossa autoestima do nosso amor
próprio da nossa identidade aconteça
é no trabalho que desenvolveu as como
trancista tenho a chance de perceber
como toda essa ressignificação funciona
na prática diariamente e o nosso que há
quase uma mágica a cada atendimento EA
cada processo mulheres e homens negros
que se encontram fragilizados por todas
as mazelas raciais são
inconscientemente e acolhidos em suas
dores e inseguranças enquanto faço as
suas tranças uma vez que aquele espaço é
não só um lugar de prestação de serviços
mas muitas vezes um ambiente de trocas
afetivas e de vivências enquanto pessoas
negras o que mais ouço durante os
atendimentos são histórias como é que eu
contei lá no início de traumas e
inseguranças construídos já na infância
em relação aos nossos próprios cabelos e
é nessa hora que novamente reforço que
diz só um cabelo nada existe eu Rafa sou
uma das milhares de trans iscas que
nesse momento há quatro anos como
ampliadores dessas narrativas que não
são compartilhadas na cadeira enquanto o
estamos ali trançada nós estamos aos
poucos criando um repertório de
histórias né vindas dos nossos clientes
que confirma que toda essas todas essas
dores e traumas já de uma infância em
relação aos nossos cabelos não são
individuais e nem os sentimentos são
isolados essa é uma dor coletiva e para
Além disso conseguimos mostrar aqueles
indivíduos que assim como aconteceu com
tantos outros dos nossos essa é uma dor
que pode ser curada e para algumas
centenas de histórias condicionadas eu
consigo afirmar com tranquilidade que se
olhar no espelho e enxergar a beleza no
que vê é um dos primeiros passos para
essa cura em um estudo sobre a relação
do cabelo afro com a construção da
identidade negra no Brasil Nilma Lino
Gomes uma o grande intelectual
brasileira afirma que são nestes salões
afros que o cabelo crespo visto
socialmente com o estigma da vergonha é
transformado em um símbolo de orgulho
para a pesquisadora mudar o cabelo pode
significar a tentativa do negro de sair
do lugar da inferioridade pode ainda
representar um sentimento de autonomia
Expresso nas variadas formas de poder
usá-lo podendo então dizer mais sobre o
papel social do cabelo do negro por isso
eu acredito está experimentando uma
ideia que eu chamaria de
auto-suficiência preta a nossa
comunidade tem percebido que através
deste Ofício é possível promover um
movimento que nos beneficia não só
financeiramente mas culturalmente também
e que altera nossa existência enquanto
sociedade temos re significado a nossa
profissão
retomado as nossas bom e como
consequência de tudo isso estamos
assistindo milhares de mulheres negras
liderança que os negócios sustentando as
suas casas circulando em novos espaços e
conseguiram se consolidar
profissionalmente tudo isso através
dessa ferramenta e ancestral que é saber
transar temos vivenciado Nesse contexto
e crescimento né dos das Tranças a
possibilidade de se construir o que
historicamente nos foi legado e que para
muitos de nós é inédito que basicamente
é o desenvolvimento de uma autoestima a
partir do que é a nossa própria
identidade eu entendo que estamos em
tempos em locais diferentes da história
contada sobre aquela África pré-colonial
nós resgatamos esse passado para
construção de uma consciência sobre a
nossa ancestralidade mas não podemos
idealizar uma conexão linear em que o
uso das Tranças se o possui os mesmos
significados que vimos nessa história
nós atravessamos processos históricos
que mudam a forma como utilizamos desse
saber mas isso não diminui a sua
importância e o impacto que isso tem nas
nossas vidas Hoje
Somos verdadeiras dessa história e nesse
saberes também e utilizamos disso de
modo que faça sentido na forma como
essas pessoas negras experimentam as
suas vivências hoje de fato podemos
acreditar que vivenciando da nossa do
nosso jeito uma certa experiência do
nosso modo atravessamos o ritual que
para muitas de nós é comemorativo
sagrado no nosso contexto a ou transar
nossos cabelos o enxergando como uma
reafirmação estética também colocamos
nele e um sentido político social
identitária um trans estão cada vez mais
sendo reconhecidas e ganhando espaço no
mercado de trabalho vivence a
independência financeira se tornando
referência né Para Além do transar e sim
isso diz muito sobre como nossos
inserimos em sociedade e no mundo
percebo que nesse movimento temos
transformado o sentido dado aos nossos
cabelos o sentido dado ao momento de
cuidar das suas tranças e das Tranças de
alguém sentido esse no ato de transar
que tem permitido o que façamos um
entrelace entre o nosso passado e as
experiências de impacto que esse
procedimento tem oferecido hoje aos
nossos entre elas somos a nossa história
EA sensualidade com um momento de afeto
e cuidado no agora e esse é o verdadeiro
significado para mim do que é transar e
E aí